what is up there reject nation what's
happening here egg and aaron here today
we are going to watch invincible episode
7 called we need to talk what a good
teaser title aaron thank you for being
here subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for invincible is up
hit that like button too helps out the
algorithm i want to thank all the people
who come back to watch our invincible
reactions means a lot to have you here
seriously it is a
random little special show for aaron and
i
i'm gonna be editing these highlights
these are probably up two weeks from the
time we filmed them and i'm sorry for
getting to you so late the finale is
already out
mention everything oh yeah
full length watch alongs to our patreon
page
and uh yeah we got a bunch of other
shows there too they were shooting this
i got my second vaccine shot nine hours
ago so you know just trying to keep keep
it cool right now how you feeling man
you know this is film this is the show
and uh we'll see how it goes
[Music]
he didn't
here sleep go answers oh my god oh my
god i'm so scared dude did they threaten
me or mark no
then why
why there's a lot of things i thought i
knew about you
the guardians were our friends how close
were you guys really
more of acquaintances
you need to leave
debbie
get out of my house
you don't mean that no no no no no he's
going to kill you he's not going to kill
her
oh no maybe he's going to kill her
oh no he's not we'll talk later geez
whoo
he still loves you good
oh it's real he loves real i mean it's a
little bit of domestic violence that was
a little bit just uh yeah yeah that was
pretty bad that's pretty bad the walls
in the ceiling yeah yeah yeah there's
some evidence
that's bad that's all bad
debbie i'm sorry but you have to come
with us there's no time oh damn they got
pretty much the confession now from
nolan
oh yeah yeah because they were listening
the whole time that's right he didn't
say it directly but it's there it's
implied yeah i've been an [ __ ] and
i'm sorry i didn't realize that sooner
but that all stops today sure
i'm in
she thought he was gonna stay in love
she's not ready for that right now
uh this is gonna fight her a window oh
my god it's okay
this is why i'm always late or why i
don't show
oh my okay we're just doing this going
to mars
i wanted to tell you so many times
she came naked
did you hear what i just said
i know you're a superhero why oh she
does know
i figured it out weeks ago oh my god
damn thank you
[Laughter]
you should have said something though
you think that's enough oh no
fly away fly boy or take the stairs i
really don't give a [ __ ] oh man freaking
pivot all that crap it was like freaking
amber was going to figure this out
it's like the show just looks at you
every episode yeah i know everything i'm
sorry
[Laughter]
i would never let you die die die
die die die oh no
what is happening step back
please
oh oh god what is that come now i
believe you can answer that question on
your own oh jeez
i like you better as the robot figures i
finally fall for someone and then
boom
cyborg
[Laughter]
[Music]
should have listened to my dad omni man
oh of course
your dad's omni man
i'm not sure we could kill him not us
anyway
but maybe mark can't only one person i
know they collected his blood though
what if they're like gonna create a
clone like a super boy situation i think
it's saying mark no never
you can't where's mark debbie oh no yeah
that's true oh
he got like very carried away this
little clone theory right you're right
[Laughter]
remember you're my son and i'm a girl
yeah
why did you kill them i just want to
know why why i already forgive you i was
never that attached to the guardians
they were only in one episode they were
a justice league ripoff
just tell me why
oh
hurry please
air is toxic to me it burns
my lungs
damn that sucks that's really awful
yeah
shitty life that's for sure
you're all slimy
it creates a copy of your mind for you
nothing will change
for him
everything will oh man why does he care
to clone himself so he can be with
monster girl but he can't transport the
mind is what they were just saying he
said maybe he's going to share it share
the mind
he's going to oh god
the system wasn't designed for neurons
going to be close is not good enough
it's not all the way
it's only close
it's just there it's just short oh no
that's the rex clone too
these give me two rexes
oh god what's gonna what's gonna happen
with the story you won the coin toss
champ you're the new one um
i see this feeling of continuance
close my eyes and open new ones
oh no
experience everything
we never could
oh
hmm i can put you back in the pod
we can both survive
wow
together
[Music]
please
wow
oh man this is
blowing my mind right now
now that our deal is complete
it's time you both return to prison
what
you savaged that's messed up man
oh it's snapped that's awesome i forgot
about the neural link there my plan
was not to hurt you
but here we are
oh he's got a robot
[Music]
that's his power oh [ __ ]
that's awesome
crazy wow look like a pumpkin
[Laughter]
debbie
what did you do she snitched on you dude
[Music]
dude this is only more condemning
look at him go oh my this is so cool
okay i just i love the way they visually
capture that that's awesome
i feel your pain girl
ah
oh [ __ ] yeah oh shit's right man
oh yeah
he's like dark siding this man looking
kool-aid man in this [ __ ] oh
lap yeah oh
oh
got him
kinda come on bobby
no
no no
bobby
oh no
oh
finish him
oh no
oh
coulson
bobby coulson may not even hurt him at
all
damn i don't know who nolan is
i don't know what he's going to do he's
going to come right there dude
oh no
oh no
he's looking for a son man
omni
mr grayson
uh mr mustache uh where's mark william
yeah you were supposed to drop him off
an hour ago oh no there was his attack
at the college and and all of a sudden
oh jeez you don't gotta be like this man
that's not
blood on you is it
dude
no one's like the cat's out of the bag
i'm caught
[Laughter]
he needs one of those spinning ball
things so we know he's still alive i'm
very much alive oh
he's going straight out you all know me
as robot but my real name is rudolph
connors
though i'd prefer if you called me rudy
rudy ask me something only robot would
know
why the [ __ ] dude
what great posture he has
[Laughter]
excellent form good man
wow
whoa
that is
wow
that animation blowing up the kent farm
yeah
damn
it's a little extreme
just a tad i'm just a buy
sometime who's coming for you
he's never hit him again
you crazy
that did nothing
oh god
[Music]
my god bleeding a lot
why me i mean sure i get that anyone
would want to be me but why specifically
why a kid version of me that's just
weird
you did it for me hey
a smart little 26 year old prisoners in
our own bodies still hasn't told me why
he stole my kid face you're ruining my
childhood
i noticed monster girl found you
interesting i don't even know how to
feel about that
god damn it robot will you please stop
[ __ ]
i know why cecil's holding us at high
alert
oh no don't be stupid guys
i'll tell you what that is not our
problem anymore
the world was fine before i came along
it'll be fine without my help better
probably man
self-loathing pitiful petty yeah
oh dark night of the soul here for mark
mm-hmm
because of a girl dude i love all this
omni man [ __ ]
oh my god i am terrified
oh good he's faster than him
after everything that we've been through
keep out of this cecil
keep out of this let me kill you
i just want to know why
yeah one of the guardians
please please tell us please mr omniman
you had a reason you want to get it off
your chest
oh
okay just gonna swap the air you can't
stop me yeah you're right i can't but i
can do the same thing i've been doing
since i figured out you were a lying
piece of [ __ ]
i can buy us a little more time
oh
got you a little boss got him whoo
oh
he took the cyborgs
because they get hurt mark oh wow
oh my god
oh my god
oh
dead soldiers serving their country one
last time
[Music]
clever
[Music]
i thought he was gone my mistake
oh
oh no
oh even the people there are like i
don't want to watch this right
i'm going on my lunch break
even invincible are back on the move
intercept in four minutes [ __ ]
sir
and victor
that's the name of the show
[Laughter]
that's your husband debbie
yikes he's a monster
oh dude omni man's the best part of this
ship oh yeah i'm almost done here
what
i love this like desperation to stop him
and everything
we removed his pain center and juiced it
up with every drug enhancement and
upgrade we had oh my
two news
helicopters moving in on omni man's
fight two news helicopters oh no
that's right from the sushi when he said
want sushi
here to make sure you don't get hurt
well then you shouldn't have come jesus
all falling apart it's about time we did
a team up oh no
not the team up here before man
bro
come on
but first mark i need to give a speech i
practiced i killed i'm a monster
i killed the guardians
in there
i can't do that
now i don't know if mark is with his
father or against him this is why i have
always goddammit says so just but i was
like almost 100 of your side
he's gray
he's
he's neutral he has to preserve
he has to do his job he's on a salary
and so it all comes down to
a job
don't miss my bonus
was he kind of like vandal savage
was he lincoln what they just tried to
say
all right
where is it you're gonna destroy robot
and the new guardians of the globe oh no
oh
oh man you guys just had the worst
string alone all these pieces coming
together man i'm so
i'm so excited
and scared
because they have to defeat omniman is
to fight the teen teen so okay i told
eve to stay away it's not adam eve oh
what
oh
oh
it's like superman bursting black adam
right yeah i see it
or j jonah jameson versus abraham
all lincoln apart
oh no
oh
that's a good one nominee man
what is happening
oh my god
i mean how shitty everyday would it be
if mortals just died again
same way
ah
again
freaking again
and the world sees
oh no he's tainted forever just go full
villain full tilt
oh
bad
oh no oh no
oh man this is not good
oh
get him yeah
freaking
become the mountain ah
oh no
somebody get that man some clear eyes
oh he sees his dad be a monster no
mark
do you have contacts
we need to talk damn
oh [ __ ] is this the last line of the
episode please don't be the last one
no no we got the are you serious no
there's no after credits
for this one i'd be okay with it not
having one yeah but i'm so mad
i just want to know i just want to know
guys i just want to know man yo that was
crazy
yeah
that was the best that was
the best one yeah [ __ ] that was crazy
hands down i was lost in that wow man
there's so much stuff happened this is a
roller coaster and the crazy thing is
you have the everything that happened in
the episode it was set up from the other
episodes but just like the confrontation
through that we need to talk in the
beginning was all set up within this one
it was very very well constructed that
was a damn good episode that was uh my
favorite episode nolan is the best part
of this show this was his episode yeah
and we still don't know
why
it's so insufferable it's like
it's on par with the falcon winter
soldier thing with freaking falcon suit
you know like you wanted to see it you
want to know this is very frustrating
but i'm excited i mean this is a little
crazier to me there's got to be a much
bigger context yeah i mean true but like
same sort of effect but yeah i want to
know more why he did it more than i care
about seeing the the suit yeah let's
compare them yeah let's compare that
same show this is about yeah
what's better
i really really thought the structure of
this was cool like kind of what you were
talking about didn't confess to debbie
he's caught in the y and then he's like
building up to at least telling mark i
love that how he has that motif he's
isolated he's prepping his speech to
talk to mark give it to him that way he
can tell him before he finds out any
other way but once he comes home and
then cecil and his like cecil's men are
there the structure and the escalation
of the action scenes throughout this
episode was
excellent yeah it was excellent like
when he shows up in his home and he just
i love the the way they visually realize
that with the with the all the people
invisible just like it's kind of like
like running into them with weapons and
stuff and like how some parts of the
body would show and the reveal of them
from going invisible to being visible
and then from there on after the
explosion across the street he's like
screw it cat's out of the back
it's been like the whole episode and
he's so angry he's so aggressive and he
still so
cares about debbie and mark yeah which
gives it like a different heart to it
because he's clearly doing villains
murder left and right
like he's murdering all over the place
it's not like a scary cat to the bag i'm
freaking evil you know
he's still he still seems like there's a
he has a purpose like they still trying
to fulfill right now and this is now a
new obstacle and and like that whatever
that purpose is is also interfered by
him wanting to get back to his family
but it's like once he's caught by cecil
it's like screw it you know no i'm not
gonna hide it even when he confronts
mark's friend who doesn't kill
he's just still like threatening towards
him yeah yeah yeah like you definitely
got a lot more shades of like what
homelander does in the in the dark you
know he's not quite like evil not evil
but like uh he's not quite out there
showing his true colors but now no one's
like screw it the mail's gone very
compelling i know something about it
reminded me of thanos it might not be
it might have been infinity war a little
bit him like going through the different
trials to kind of find his that solution
though the context is completely
different just something about it
reminded me of that well there's
something fano thanos asking the sense
of how he's not just like i said it's
not just full-blown evil i think what
makes it so gripping is that something
that's that it that is felt that's
percolating throughout this whole
episode is that he really really cares
to get back to debbie and mark
you know and that provides a different
edge to it it's not really about like
whatever this bigger reason is for
why he killed the guardians it's about
trying to stay alive not get caught and
he wants to get to mark you know like
that gives it is this like strength
similar to how thanos really has this
like weird way of being a father and and
how his his goal with like 50 percent of
the like whatever cleansing thing
there's like this good in his own mind
behind what he's doing so that makes it
more compelling to watch yeah and that's
what made this so gripping what makes it
different from thanos though is the
whole there's a lot of debbie
what they're not the same characters
trying to help your point you're trying
to spin me and i appreciate it remind
you of thanos and now you're coming here
like here's why he's different i'm like
i'm not sure i already trying to help
you
trying to spin us out of the thanos but
the different
thing is debbie was was really a player
in this episode you know i feel like she
did uh
a lot in terms of being there and kind
of fully distancing herself from nolan
you know she she's fully committed to
like okay i can't trust this man i don't
know this man but she still loves him
you know and like she just cares about
him there's her husband for 20 years you
know so even though she wants nothing to
do with him when cecil was like i'm
sorry i mean it was about mark i feel
like part of her still cares but we'll
see if hopefully they have one last
confrontation with one another well i
think what was cool about what they did
with debbie emotionally here because she
doesn't get like a bunch of dialogue you
kind of watch
the uh conflict and the horror the
realization of the terror slowly like
the love starts to kind of melt a little
bit away or like kind of start to like
incinerate within her because she starts
off in at the beginning of this like you
can't just kill
nolan you're a monster cecil the more
nolan
just lets himself let loose with
murdering and there's drones and cameras
watching him and you keep cutting back
to debbie having to see like oh my god
he's really like she's just has to keep
dealing more and more and more and more
he's a monster he's a monster he's not
the man i know like you go from that
conflicted feeling of there's got to be
a reason why you killed the guardians
too as she's watching this she's going
no he's he's a monster he's like from
her perspective yeah her heart is
shattering more and more every time you
come back to her yeah yeah she's like
when you first see her she's like you
know she loves her husband and then over
the the course of the events ah you're
you're evil you murder met people right
that's exactly what you said
[Laughter]
mark's mine you'll never get a hand on
him
and that's the cat's meow but the
build-up of the fights with them was so
cool because you have the cyborgs that
show up yeah monster cyborgs that show
up you pointed out how they were able to
take out mark i'm like oh damn i totally
missed that detail like oh [ __ ] that was
just because mark was still kind of
amateur at this and and uh then you see
why they kept them on board like they're
preparing this threat i have me thinking
of like what amanda waller's purpose is
mm-hmm suicide squad like we never know
if superman might turn back
how much like he still had all these
weapons already in case superman turned
bad it's this act of escalating
desperation to stop nolan the the the
way how the fights progress of how
there's like the big
um satellite laser missile law that the
thing that creates like an atomic
blasting and then they send in the evil
cyborgs and they send in the freaking
giant ass kaiju looking good
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah monster yeah and i love how they're
also like the only person who can stop
him is mark probably probably need mark
and then they're like get mark there
mark's helping him because mark doesn't
know what the hell is going on he thinks
his dad's a date right
and then and then mark's about to die
and then you got a mortal showing up
immortal you're like yeah i totally get
why mortals mad at why he wants to kill
him makes absolute perfect sense why he
wants to murder him and i'm not against
them what immortals trying to do at all
that's what timing is through your time
because mark's going to die right you
keep interrupting this i'm saving his
son yeah so it's such a great you know
like a better word it's a great
[ __ ] that's why i love it so much
it's super [ __ ] yeah it's just
like collapsing all left and right in in
uh cleverly constructed directions with
mark being probably the least
interesting part of this episode
mark has been a whiny little baby the
whole time oh i'm sorry my girlfriend is
going to be with me because i'm a bad
boyfriend
he was being a little little crybaby
about it dude you gotta grow up yeah but
i mean you're about to you're about to
find out some answers so you are growing
up i mean i get it he's a teenager he's
discovered his powers got an ego i get
what they're doing i mean i remember in
the last episode actually i i saw some
comments of people being like actually
mark really annoyed me in this episode
mark really frustrated me in this
episode that was a little bit more
forgiving when i was like parts of it
are annoying sure
but here it was like
quit self-pitying yourself right now all
right you gotta do it it's a human
reaction i get it but enough people have
been like dude
cut it out
exactly like you're timing like that
contrast with the stuff that's going on
in the show his timing was just really
terrible but you know
he's more human because of that you know
because there's so many parallels
between him and peter parker so like man
i don't think peter would do this [ __ ]
but like he's not peter because he has
different parents in a different
circumstance and background but similar
sort of experiences dating and being
young and figuring yourself out it's
interesting that
those two characters with similar sort
of paths will have different results in
the way they'd handle problems true but
they did address the amber thing right
away oh yeah i'm happy she knew we went
to town in the last discussion
about how ridiculous it is amber does it
now yeah and then right away you're like
oh she like knew for a while
but also i was like why don't you just
say something i feel like if you figured
it out just say something you don't have
to be like i'm just going to wait till
he tells me
but it kind of makes you look back a
little bit she seemed really hurt that
when mark
like mark left them yeah when the month
cyborg showed up at the college campus
right where did you go like she acted
like you you betrayed me and ran away
out on me yeah wouldn't you have known
at that time but it sounds like you knew
then
based off what you were saying here how
long have you known exactly time has
really just learned and you're acting
like yeah right time is really weird in
this show like it's already been five
months i'm like damn what he still saved
you at the campus where he's mad that he
was just not telling you still that he
was invincible all the anger was emperor
yeah we weren't a little grateful that
he was there to save the day you know it
doesn't make sense it just doesn't make
sense but at least she knows and she
knows yeah and then of course robot let
me play ralph boner was his name
i was chirping balls on the whole clone
thing because it's not a transportation
of the m it's not transporting my
consciousness into the clone this clone
is just getting a duplication of my mind
yeah
exactly um in the air with the right
spot but that was the most original
stuff i've seen in like a comic book
property and then any show the response
that like clone
robot rex had where he was like crying
for him and sympathetic like no i could
save you like wow
i don't even know put this to put it
into words or whatever i don't i don't
know how to put it into words any time
to ruminate on that i was i was really
my mind was just going through like wow
this is so trippy yeah
it was it was not the response you would
expect like we can build the world
together it was very sad and i was like
i'm why am i so sad and like feeling so
many feels for this version of robot
that we just met you know and just like
it was just so authentic it hit the
fields hit right here i'd like the clone
to be reacting to your dying self i
think it helps with like the contrast of
the mueller twins
of having them that there's always like
i'm the original clone no i'm there like
there's always a argument about it yeah
and then to have them wake up and it's
like but the mind of i forget the guy's
name whoever robot is is a very
rudy rudolph i think i think you're
right about that yeah uh
let's call him robot to be safe
at the mind of a robot that operates
differently so it's like they're
compassionate towards one another how he
wanted to die so
he could still live on even though he's
not technically the one living on and
then the clone is feeling
heartbroken and it's like he's watching
himself die essentially but at the same
time he's watching some other being he
really cares about there's just like so
many different crashes
yeah yeah yeah existential elements just
all meshing together yeah i think i get
what you're saying a sense of
superiority in the fact
between the molar twins like i'm the i'm
the original i'm the one who's better
but with the the robot twins there's a
sense of like love and like no we can be
better together it doesn't have to be
one better than the other and how do you
feel together one wanted to die
being because he cared so much to still
carry on his work and to also be with
monster girl yeah like it's so
there's so much like to unpack in that
one moment when he's crying like i can't
this is this is heavy
that was like some of the heaviest [ __ ]
i've seen in a while and that would have
been really trousy if they both lived
because they'd both love monster girl
yeah but like one guy did not care
because it works on such a different
level because he didn't transport his
consciousness exactly it's just
duplicated one has a different mindset
to live on and the other has a different
mindset to die yeah but essentially they
have the same heart you know yeah so
maybe physically yeah yeah soul is a
better word for that yeah
just a different point it's trippy it's
trippy stuff it really is it's it's like
there's a lot of layers there yeah who
knew and thought and vince will be so
deep man doesn't come in the form of
mark sometimes because
i love it but that's like hilarious like
when rex is confronting his younger self
like he just can't get of course he's
like tripping balls i love how they're
all like you didn't think we questioned
this robot like what the hell this is
this is insane but when you see the life
that rude rudy yeah pretty he left that
off pretty rudolph pad
[Music]
[Laughter]
that he had
he's like well i get why he kind of
misses out on a few like anticipating
some actual human responses and
reactions these have to be all logical
than mine in numbers
yeah i think the combination of i've
seen like elements of those things
before like modoc like someone who's
like has a big brain but can't move his
body but also just the combination of
like the
like the try about the i lose comedy
series modoc
comedy studios
like may 31st
modoc bodies can't move it kind of
reminded me of that and like ultron or
iron man like controlling the multiple
bodies but it's not like it's not ai
like that's literally his intelligence
the tragedy about it kind of reminded me
of mr freeze as well like just all of
those elements coming together was was
and the way it was constructed was very
original there's just some rich scenes
in here too like i love the scene with
cecil and nolan confronting each other
over the truth
now that cecil can be like i know what
you did why did you do it
and nolan having to deal with
yeah nolan having to deal with all this
was just so powerful that hook of just
at the end we need to talk like
look
but even dude
what's up and i was gonna say even when
he was talking about the when he was
talking to the immortal he was saying
like you're weak like he uh confirms his
like superiority complex over the rest
of the world
immortal wakes up and this is like that
foreign
so powerful yeah it's my favorite one
man yeah hands down this is my favorite
one everyone's so good everyone the the
gray area of like characters like cecil
too like i like i really like celso a
lot in this episode yeah i love the
escalating collapse of everything that
occurred here the uh what a great
cliffhanger
fantastic
i'm so hyped for the next one i cannot
wait all right guys well what'd you
think this episode leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click the
notification bell hit that like button
check out our reaction up
patreon
i'm not take two in that see you guys
[Music]